the war in Vietnam is a combined and
joint effort the man who is their
soldier sailor marine or airman American
Corian South Vietnamese Australian or
New Zealand er already knows this well
the unit assembled information here
somewhere in Vietnam is representative
of all I have a letter addressed to all
personnel of this command from the
commanding general during our tour in
the Republic of Vietnam we have all seen
what communism can do to a struggling
nation in our world community it is
therefore most important that we conduct
our affairs with the people of the
Republic of Vietnam in a manner that
will show the Vietnamese citizen that we
are his friends and that we are here to
assist him in the improvement as well as
the security of this country it is then
with great pride that I note the fine
work done by the soldiers of this
command during the recent operation it
is with pleasure that I say a job well
done
these men have just emerged from many
long days of combat during which they
faced in fought the Vietcong drove him
from areas that which he had heretofore
control open roads for travel which he
had dominated and thereby contributed
substantially to the turning of the tide
yet it is not for their military
accomplishments alone important though
they are that they are commanded by the
commander
it is for other activities more subtle
less easy to grasp and define it every
bit is indispensable to the final
decision in the war it has been fun
Vietnam today a war unique in the long
history of armed conflict between men
and Nations
some of the images of men at war don't
change much across the generations the
ragged soldier who stood with Washington
at Valley Forge seems to us almost to be
a part of our own time so immediate and
meaningful is the symbol he presents the
tragic figures of the men in blue and
gray who fought the civil war that
decided our courses nation are not just
misty historical shapes they are
familiar to us as part of our national
experience now these are photographs
taken by army cameramen of the war in
Vietnam but because the scenes of all
wars are so much the same they evoke
memories in many of us of other battles
in other times there are men who can
look at this picture and remember with a
sharp tug that dissolves the years what
it was like in those brief lulls between
the battles of two decades ago and
others will think of Korea and the
blistering summer heat of that war for
those who were there this could be from
any one of a dozen campaigns in the
Pacific here's a shot of men and tanks
moving out together to close with the
enemy and here's one of the Warriors
searching for spiritual strength images
of men in combat which could be as much
a part of the recent past as the present
but for all the similarities there are
differences - some of these are physical
many of the techniques of war for
instance changes technology advances in
Vietnam the helicopter dramatizes that
technological revolution the fighting
men they're employed this machine to
defeat problems of distance and terrain
in a way that would have seemed
incredible to the men who had to storm
the murderous mountains of Korea and
probably no servicemen who has had to
fight through Vietnam monsoons will ever
believe there was anything like it in
any other war at any time but most of
all - the men who are there the
distinctively urgent fact
about Vietnam or the kind of war the
enemy is fighting and the special
problems of the people not that the
tragedy of uprooted people is new to the
soldier it's not he's been forced to
witness this ugly manifestation of war
many times before and he has helped
whenever he can as he is doing in
Vietnam today to alleviate the problems
and the suffering of the people among
whom he moves and lives and fights but
there's a difference in Vietnam a big
difference and it revolves around the
people and it is this difference that
makes the war they're unique in the
experience of the American soldier
although this story we bring you today
is basically a story of a soldier in
Vietnam it is broader than that it is
the story of all our servicemen
defending against aggression in that
far-off land and more it is the story of
the special task which all of them have
of helping to build a nation at the
grassroots level among the people in the
villages this is the battleground in
Vietnam the varied and changing face of
the land
but this too is the battlefield the
villages and the Hamlet's which dot the
countryside the communities across the
land where four-fifths of the people
live and it is in this battlefield that
the issue of victory or defeat will
ultimately be decided the reason is
rooted in the special nature of the war
that is being fought here for this is a
war whose objective is to win the hearts
and the minds of the people to
understand why this is so it is
necessary to contrast this war with
those we have fought in the past take
Korea for example as in all the wars
before it it had a battle when the war
was going against us the battle line
pushed in on us
but when we were on the offensive the
movement of the battle line described
the progress of our victory in this
normal kind of military situation the
other side of that line was known to be
enemy territory and tragic though it was
it was a fact to be accepted that cities
and towns lying in areas controlled by
the enemy often had to suffer the cost
of victories advance
but the war in Vietnam is different
although our forces to engage in
conventional combat with well organized
North Vietnamese military units who
support the Viet Cong guerrillas the
enemy is active over most of the
countryside and rarely is there a
conventional battle on the job of the
fighting men here is to search the enemy
out wherever he hides
however he travels and supplies his
forces to seek Him along all the avenues
through which he infiltrates the
republic of vietnam carrying the weapons
of his aggression
their job is to find him
and then destroy him but because the
enemy over here is fighting basically an
unconventional war he does not rely on
holding terrain but more importantly the
people the foundation of unconventional
war rests on the need for their support
in this kind of struggle whoever has the
people wins the war so it becomes the
task of our troops to deny the enemy the
popular support he has to have in order
to survive more than that our troops
must enlist that popular support behind
their own effort and behind the
government of the Republic of Vietnam it
is that government whose cause the
American soldier represents to the
people through whose villages he travels
and fights so the issue turns on the
people in their villages and hamlets and
these become the ultimate battlefield of
the war as our side and the enemy both
endeavor to win their support as the war
thus absent flows through their lives
and villages the people themselves have
little control over that constant
movement nor ironically is the grave
issue of the war the threat to freedom
which communist aggression poses always
clear for the people who support will
determine the ultimate decision their
lives are lived at the edge of
fundamental experiences and it is the
fundamentals with which they are
concerned poverty hunger disease and a
deep yearning to live in peace and
without fear or they have known the
trials of war now for many long years
their allegiance will go inevitably to
the side which most clearly demonstrates
a sympathetic interest in those
fundamental problems the winning of
their support then takes other weapons
beyond those in our arsenal of firepower
it takes the intangible weapons of
compassion and goodwill in the early
phase of the war
the Vietcong proved themselves adept at
using those weapons simply by persuading
the people that they were their friends
and protectors would help to bring them
a better life
the real objectives of communism were
always under played or obscured entirely
they're still doing that as much as they
can but one factors changed the
direction of the war significantly the
big buildup of American forces
with the build up the vietcong's hold on
the countryside started to loosen and as
that has happened
the enemy has turned more and more to
the use of terror and murder as a way of
maintaining his grip on the people
hoping to intimidate them into support
as the voluntary support weakens there's
been his greatest mistake for although
it can have immediate effect its
long-term result can only work against
him
the enemy's mistakes of course worked to
our advantage but there is an obvious an
urgent lesson never to duplicate those
mistakes not to be sure that there is
any danger of our forces ever using
terrorism as a weapon but the people in
the villages might not always be able to
distinguish the difference between the
calculated cruelty of communist forces
and fire which rains on them and their
families from an American rifle or an
American plane these special demands of
this special war place a particular
responsibility on every American in
Vietnam commanders at all levels are
obliged to consider the psychological as
well as the military objectives of each
operation and because the circumstances
call for an exercise restraint beyond
that normally required on a battlefield
they must strike a balance between the
force essential to accomplish their
mission and the necessity of inflicting
as few casualties as possible on the
civilian population now this does not
mean that the rules of safety and
security can ever be relaxed every
commander must always be able to
accomplish his mission with the least
loss to his own troops the fewest
possible restrictions on his planning
and his freedom to fire and maneuver
nor does it mean that men going into
battle should ever place their own lives
or those of their buddies in jeopardy
through excessive caution every man must
take with him into combat the certain
knowledge that he has the inherent right
always to defend himself against hostile
action wherever and whenever it occurs
but this special responsibility does
mean that firepower of all kinds has to
be employed with care taken insofar as
is humanly possible to avoid unnecessary
damage to the lives and property of the
civilian population for the blunt truth
is that death or injury to helpless
civilians even when it is unavoidable
works against us this knowledge is
simply one of the conditions of war
which must be accepted
this special responsibility extends all
the way along the chain of command on
every level and in every service and it
very specifically includes the man on
the ground must face his personal
responsibilities through the sights of
his personal weapon
for this man's job carries him into the
very heart of this unique battlefield
precautions to eliminate needless
casualties are taken whenever possible
such as broadcasts or leaflets to warn
civilians of impending airstrikes or
operations always of course with duty
guard given to the security the success
of the mission
kundo it the villages have to be entered
they have to be searched and made safe
this remains an inescapable duty of war
but with careful plans made and executed
with every precaution taken it can be
within the bounds of safety and with
every man aware of his own increased
responsibility this done with the least
possible damage in danger
operations planned in coordination with
the country's province or district
Chiefs help smooth the path the rest of
the way for they can explain better than
anyone else at least in the beginning
that the Americans are here as friends
about McDonald okay give me this friends
that's how our forces come into the
villages of Vietnam friendship is one of
the most basic gifts a man can offer it
is built on the desire really to know
people the soldier has a special
opportunity to try to understand what
Vietnam enix people are like Vietnam is
an old country with a recorded history
that goes back more than 2,000 years its
traditions and its customs are ancient
and deeply cherished
the Vietnamese himself humble peasant
though he may be is the inheritor of
this old tradition and anyone who had
claimed his friendship must understand
that about him
he looks on the world in a very set way
defined and shaped by a long tradition
it is a world that lies always close to
the soil of the elements
this village is more than his home it is
his universe and he seldom if ever
leaves it the values which shape his
code of behavior are his most precious
possessions and they are honored ones
dignity self-control respect for elders
his family is all important to him all
his family not only those immediately
close to him but distant relatives as
well those living those dead and those
in generations yet to come
regard for the family is at the center
of his religion the majority of villages
in Vietnam are Buddhist many like this
one are Catholic some were Protestant
whichever it is the place of worship in
the village is the focal point of
community life knowing these things
about the Vietnamese people and
understanding the importance they have
in their lives help our troops to
establish the friendship that is so
crucial to their mission
you
but beyond endeavoring to know and
understand the Vietnamese there is much
more for the soldier to do
one again Airport please with which the
American fighting man establishes
rapport with the children in the land
see that she travels is an enduring part
of his legend there is no mystery about
it for the hungry language of childhood
is universal and men at war have known
for generations that candy and chewing
gum bring smiles warm the hearts of
children in any land
but there is more to this legend than
candy and gifts and every man knows it
who has watched happiness brightening I
have a child as the result of his own
effort it does not always happen quickly
even a child's friendship is sometimes
slow to come and how much more true this
is of people who have known bitterly
only the brutality of war and warriors
and who can escape only behind thick
walls of silence and suspicion their
friendship has not obtained easily but
with patience and effort it can be won a
civic action plan supports every
military operation not because we
believe that friendship has a price
which we can pay with giveaways and
handouts but because we thus have the
opportunity to show in a definite
tangible way that our interests really
lie with the people and their problems
food and sometimes clothing supplied by
the various aid agencies are often is
important to take on combat operations
as any other kind of cargo they are not
lightly given nor are they lightly
received
the people who live always on the edge
of want whose days blend into a
continuing challenge to rest enough from
the earth to still their children's
hunger such gifts are deeply important
and the gesture of giving becomes deeply
meaningful
to people whose lives are shadowed and
haunted by disease who must suffer pain
and illness because no help for
suffering is available to them who is
health and well-being are doomed to the
harsh conditions of a harsh life to such
a people the attentions of a military
medical team are powerful symbols indeed
of a desire for friendship
even soap in the community which has not
and therefore is vulnerable to the
ravages that such a simple item can
prevent becomes a weapon with almost
magic powers
every military unit has the capability
of helping to improve a community in
some way simple construction material
for instance and a little paint and a
few hours work and pay rich and lasting
dividends particularly work done side by
side with the people themselves for the
Vietnamese people are both proud and
industrious they welcome the assistance
of our forces and together they can
accomplish much a new roof for the
community meeting center a place for the
children to go to school a new face for
the house of worship a well a bridge
these can work for us with wonderful
effect helping the people to gather in
their precious rice crop and protect it
from the Viet Cong as these Marines are
doing can be as important as any
military engagement for all of this is
evidence which will stand as lasting
reminders that the Americans who came
this way as allies of their government
came as friends
establishing friendships in the villages
of Vietnam can also produce tangible
results intelligence information for
instance which can save the lives of
American troops the war our forces wage
in Vietnam today is slow and hard and
grinding from the storehouse of our
nation's power they are bringing to it
the might with which they can eventually
destroy the enemy strength from
reservoirs of compassion and generosity
they bring a spirit and a demonstration
of friendship and these two become
weapons as powerful as any other in this
war which is a contest for the hearts
and the minds of the people of Vietnam
they are weapons that will touch and
stir the hopes of those through whose
villages the fighting men travel and
when they pass on will leave it to
positive warm feelings behind
you
let's go
and so they move on through village
after village hopefully leaving new
friends as they travel up now that
doesn't mean that each village is
secured forever when they leave it on oh
no the war isn't that simple but their
job is to continue pressing a war until
the enemy they fight is convinced his
aggression will not pay and hand in hand
with their fighting the soldiers in
Vietnam must carry on their crucial task
of helping to build a nation all the way
to the heart and soul the smallest
hamlet